hey guys how's going as you might have
seen in the background of some of my
newer videos I do have some artwork that
I did hanging on the wall I've always
been into art and drawing portraits and
I actually wanted to be a cartoonist
when I was young but recently I visited
my friend from college who does a lot of
charcoal portraits and he gave me some
tips and pointers and help me get back
into drawing you can check out his
channel at the portrait art where you
can check out his website at wwlp.com he
has a lot of really good speed drawing
videos on his channel
so be sure to check them out what I
wanted to do in this video is just to
briefly display some of the art work
that I did and to see if you guys could
tell who the person is that I've drawn
each of the drawings took roughly six
hours and we're done with charcoal
pencil at the end of the video I'll
display who it is that I've drawn so
thanks a lot for watching alright this
is a portrait that I did on September
21st of a an actor who is in a movie
recently and some of you guys actually
guessed who this was when I had it in
the background of my other video my
friend helped me with this directly when
I visited him on the weekend of the 21st
all right this next drawing that I did
on September 25th is of an actor who is
in a TV show that's pretty popular some
of you probably watch it and this took
me a little bit of time because I kept
on messing up his nose I made it a
little bit longer than it's supposed to
be so it was a little bit frustrating
but overall I think it came out pretty
good
all right this next drawing is of an
actress who isn't also in a TV show and
I did this one on September 24th again I
kept on messing up the nose a little bit
it was a little bit hard to get the
right curve and it took me a little bit
of time to get this one as well
all right so this is a portrait that I
did yesterday again of an actor who was
in a TV show the same TV show as the
second guy was and this one took me
roughly six and a half hours as well and
I was having some problems with the nose
and the eye position so I had to adjust
some things but overall I was pretty
happy with the result
all right so this is a portrait that I
did on September 26th and this one took
me the longest because I couldn't get
the nose right the one that you thought
would be easiest is actually the hardest
and it took me some time to get the nose
and I've still been working on it and
making adjustments but overall I think
that it looks like the person who I drew
and if you guys have been watching this
video hopefully you'd be able to tell
who this person is as well alright guys
so thanks a lot for watching the video
and I hope you enjoyed
you